so the big right-hander is out there six
five 217 pounds native of the dominican
republic 23 year old rookie edward
cabrera on the mound it's made he has
pitched 16 and a third innings so far
and has struck out just nine so the
strikeout pitch is not a big pitch for
him not yet
and there's that fastball 98 and the
first pitch is drilled toward right
center field and oh bad looking attempt
there by de la cruz and into second base
with a stand-up double on the first
pitch now set for a one-two pitch with
hayes off of second
and a swing and a miss the guy that
doesn't strike out very much changes
chases a curveball
and cabrera's got his first k wild pitch
has hayes at third
and now this kicks away and the run will
score on what is absolutely a wild pitch
and that's how they plate their first
run lead off double two wild pitches one
nothing pirates donny will say something
to him and what he's going to say is
okay you got that out of your system now
let's go
the pitch and
did he check his swing
there's an appeal
and he went around on the pitch he's out
on strikes he started the first he
wanted the walk
but it's strikeout number two for edward
cabrera here's the one and two tsatugo
swings and misses totally fooled by that
pitch which was the slider he must have
been looking fastball got the slider had
a very weak approach he could bryce
wilson there again but his fourth pitch
mix will be working at fastball and a
changeup he likes to use that fastball
has been the one that he uses most of
the time and jazz featuring red and
white shoes
there's a ball lined out into left
center that's a base hit that's a good
job of hitting the left hand hitter
taking that liner out into left center
and he does so on the seventh pitch of
the back
it off nice little play hoy park and
look at this chisholm will be doubled
off that base running huge mistake by
the rookie chisholm and the pirates get
out of it park makes a nice play and
then four to six on the out that's a
double play
edward cabrera will go back to work
comes the o2 pitch from cabrera and
there's another strikeout
swinging a miss on a pitch down and away
again the sliders he's making efficient
use of that slider here in the early
going bases are loaded pirate pitcher up
here
with two
teammates in scoring position here's the
2-2
and that's over strike three call five
strikeouts and a new career high for him
here's the pitch and that is swung on
and foul tipped right into the mint of
fortas and how about that
all six outs coming on strikeouts
through an inning and a half well
through his two innings six three 222
out of eagway dominican republic here's
the o2 strike three call wilson got a
fastball down and in on him one out
first strikeout for bryce wilson and
louis brinson comes to bat oh too he
threw a bomb and there's no doubting
that one that was a fast ball
two outs
the pitch and it's popped up into the
air shallow right center racing in
sliding under it de la cruz a circus
catch
for out number one a great jump by de la
cruz in center field and he has just
been fantastic no matter where you've
put him in the outbill this is a young
rookie who's been playing like anything
but he looks so comfortable out there
and so confident in everything he does
here's the pitch
and did he go yes he did on appeal third
base umpire said he went around
and perez is down on strikes number
seven
for edward cabrera in three innings of
work
so we had brian de la cruz and jesus
sanchez going through the lineup today
and their nickname was el nuevo the new
guy
he'll have to come up with something
else because the new guy has his first
hit
fortes goes right up the middle first
major league hit
for nick fortes tucker to lead off then
park and wilson here in the fourth
inning
and look at this cole tucker is feeling
it he's got great speed
into second base with a double and he's
not going to stop there cole tucker into
third base
easily with a trip trip triple now has
to work around a lead off triple
jazz laying out to make the catch
on the line drive by park jazz makes a
terrific play
diving for out number one
hits the ground after making the catch
held on
wilson gets the bunt down legends got it
flips it home
supplies the tag and they get tucker
well executed defense there by the
marlins
diaz to fortes and that is out number
two well now the pirates back to second
and third hayes trails wilson at third
and the pitch had a ball
poked towards second base lightly hit
it
two runs come in to score and the
marlins flub that and give the pirates a
gift-wrapped three-nothing lead jazz and
sanchez colliding in the ball falls
yeah all kinds of miscommunication
on this shallow pop-up to right it's uh
sean gunther who takes over here in the
fifth inning see we can find a way to
get this one run in with a two-out base
hit
and toward left center field well hit by
hoy park and this ball will short hop
the wall and this will score two park
headed to third and he is there with a
two run triple and the pirates take a
five-nothing lead and laywin is aboard
and nick porter's will be the banner oh
boy nick fortes fly ball left field and
it's gone
first major league home run for nick
fortes
marlins are on the board
yeah the marlins offenses needed a
wake-up call
how about nick fortes in his big league
debut
a line driving a catch by reynolds
he has perfected that dive the necessary
dive by the way yeah it's so necessary
so shinjuku now at third with two outs
and the three two coming not a swing of
the ground ball that's going to get
through the right side base hits
tsutsugo will trot in to score cole
tucker with his third hit tonight a two
strike two out rbi the pirates lead it
six to two two one and two out here for
cole tucker here's the 2-2 and the ball
is bounced back to the mound knocked
down by
williams that he picks it up in plenty
of time and gets it over to leiwen diaz
for the out one to three to end this
long half inning of baseball jason
shreve is on the pitch this will be his
51st game this year
brinson pops it up
infield comes together near the mound
and it falls
one rebel score the ball was up there
for a while key brian hayes came over
went over the mound the ball spun back
the other way
and it falls in and the marlins still
have a heartbeat tonight
got him swinging raise the jolly roger
diaz chases and the pirates hold on